la presión arterial alta o hipertensión
es una condición común en la que la
fuerza de la sangre en las paredes de
sus arterias es demasiado alta
las arterias son vasos sanguíneos que
llevan la sangre desde su corazón para
suministrar sus tejidos como oxígeno y
nutrientes
en su corazón dos cámaras llamadas
ventrículos se contraen con cada latido
para empujar la sangre hacia sus
pulmones y a través de sus arterias a su
cuerpo
a medida que la sangre fluye a través de
ellas tres factores principales afectan
la presión de sus paredes arteriales el
primero es el gasto cardíaco o el mundo
de sangre que sus ventrículos sacan de
su corazón cada minuto su presión
arterial sube a medida que el gasto
cardíaco aumenta
el segundo factor que afecta su presión
arterial es el volumen sanguíneo o el
monto total de sangre en su cuerpo la
presión arterial también se eleva a
medida que se incrementa el volumen
sanguíneo
el tercer factor que afecta su presión
arterial es la resistencia que es
cualquier cosa que trabaja contra el
flujo sanguíneo a través de sus arterias
diversos factores contribuyen a la
resistencia un factor de resistencia es
la flexibilidad de su pared arterial
las arterias saludables se expanden con
cada latido para reducir la presión
sanguínea en la pared
otro factor de resistencia es el
diámetro de sus arterias su cuerpo es
capaz de incrementar el diámetro de sus
arterias para reducir su presión
sanguínea
o reducir el diámetro para elevar su
presión sanguínea
un tercer factor de resistencia es la
viscosidad sanguínea o engrosamiento en
su sangre más partículas como proteínas
y grasas incrementan la viscosidad
si su sangre es más espesa su presión
sanguínea se eleva a medida que su
corazón trabaja más duro para empujarla
a través de sus arterias
su presión arterial puede ser medida con
un dispositivo llamado un stick
manómetro potenciómetro
cuando su corazón late la presión de la
sangre en las paredes de sus arterias es
llamada presión sistólica
cuando su corazón se relaja entre
latidos la presión en la pared arterial
es llamada presión diastólica
si bien su tensión arterial puede
cambiar a lo largo del día lo ideal es
que sea inferior a 120 milímetros de
mercurio para la tensión sistólica y
menor a 80 milímetros de mercurio para
presión diastólica si su tensión
sistólica con frecuencia se mantiene por
encima de 130 o su tensión diastólica
con frecuencia se mantiene por encima de
80 usted sufre de tensión arterial alta
con el tiempo la presión arterial alta
dañará las paredes de sus arterias
su pared arterial puede debilitarse
y formar un engrandecimiento llamado un
aneurisma o la pared puede explotar
y sangrar en el tejido que se encuentra
alrededor
pequeñas lágrimas en su pared arterial
pueden atraer ciertas sustancias en su
sangre como colesterol grasas y calcio
para formar una acumulación llamada una
placa
el flujo sanguíneo a través de su
arteria disminuye a medida que la placa
se agranda las células sanguíneas pueden
pegarse a la placa y formar montículos
sólidos llamados coágulos reduciendo o
bloqueando completamente su flujo
sanguíneo
el daño a sus arterias eleva su presión
arterial incluso más haciendo que su
corazón lata con mayor fuerza el daño
arterial y el flujo sanguíneo reducido
pueden conducir a condiciones como un
derrame cerebral
ataque al corazón
o enfermedad renal
en la mayoría de casos la presión
arterial alta o hipertensión es
desconocida este tipo de presión
arterial alta es llamada primaria o
hipertensión esencial
el tratamiento para la hipertensión
esencial incluye cambios en el estilo de
vida como comer una dieta saludable
si usted es sensible al sodio en la sal
su médico puede recomendar limitar su
consumo de sal y alimentos altamente
procesados
el sodio puede provocar que su cuerpo
retenga agua lo que incrementa tanto su
volumen sanguíneo como su presión
arterial
y otros cambios de estilo de vida que
pueden reducir la presión arterial
incluye evitar consumo de alcohol
excesivo
realizar ejercicio regular
y perder peso si está con sobrepeso
y dejar de fumar
su médico puede también recomendar
medicamentos que actúan en sus riñones
vasos sanguíneos o corazón para ayudar a
reducir su presión arterial
diuréticos comúnmente llamados pastillas
de agua provocan que sus riñones muevan
más sal y agua de su sangre a su orina
lo que reduce su volumen y presión
arterial
los bloqueadores beta reducen la carga
de trabajo en su corazón disminuyendo la
tasa de sus latidos y la fuerza de las
contracciones de su corazón
[Música]
los diversos tipos de medicamentos
actúan de forma directa o indirecta para
reducir su presión arterial relajando
sus vasos sanguíneos que incrementan el
diámetro estos medicamentos se incluyen
inhibidores ac y bloqueadores receptores
2 angiotensina bloqueadores del canal de
calcio y vasodilatadores de actuación
directa